the Disney filmmakers have left us with
a lot to be thankful for when they drop
the Lion King movie trailer on this
Thanksgiving Day the significance as a
peek of what we can expect to see from
the new movie with some awesome graphics
that I'm sure we can all appreciate for
all of our young things family members
this video is just the one for you so be
sure to keep on watching for things you
probably don't understand right now but
wale soon now let me tell you guys a few
things that 90's considered really
understand growing up so you can shop
all your friends with your newfound Lion
King expertise the 1994 classic The Lion
King was a movie bill loved by so many
kids of the time the movie brought to
life many of our favorite characters and
catchy songs that we just couldn't
imagine our Disney life without not only
was the movie one big awesome adventure
but it also taught the kids of our
generation so many lessons for starters
the hilarious do two moanin Pumbaa
show us that they don't take life too
seriously and neither should we
these two will have you singing and
dancing to Hakuna Matata in no time
Hakuna Matata what kuna Matata you know
this is a totally catchy phrase but
you're gonna understand just how
important it is as you get older getting
older can definitely be an amazing time
but it can sometimes also get
overwhelming and when it does we just
think back to the motto of our favorite
pals Timon and Pumbaa now all the talk
of Hakuna Matata what does it actually
mean I don't know about you guys but
growing up I did not know what to wanna
come by even were are you not talking
about a lion Lions eat guys like us what
do you guys think they are be sure to
let me know in the comments section I'll
be really surprised if you guess Timon
is an animal that we call a meerkat
Mia cats live in the deserts of South
Africa they like to hang out in groups
of about 20 and sometimes even 50 animal
experts call these groups games
it's true guys a group of meerkats is
called a game or a mob how funny is that
see you and your group Avenue be sure to
tag your entire squad below and let me
know
feel free to even come up with the name
for our squad right here at the things
I'll definitely be on the lookout for a
good one so have fun and get creative
don't worry I definitely didn't forget
about our buddy Pumbaa it turns out that
Timon has already let us know that
Pumbaa is a warthog he also lives in the
deserts of Africa and belongs to the pig
family now for one of my personal
favorite characters in the movie Zazu
Zazu is the ultimate sassy character of
the movie which makes it no wonder that
he comes up with the sassiest and
funniest or should I say funniest lines
of the movie just look at you two
little seeds of romance that's right
guys as a kid you might think that sauce
it is just this boring and bossy bird
that keeps trying to get some out of
trouble but the truth is he kind of has
a point for not wanting him to just walk
into an elephant graveyard check out
some of my favorite Zazu funny moments
chimps are doing great
giraffes remain above it all I know
right pretty impressive
huzzah zoo in your life everybody's got
one
even though scar is super villainous his
song be prepared is some awesome advice
that I kind of wish I paid attention to
when I was younger and no I do not mean
being prepared to be as evil as he is
while the song is super creepy and scar
is his usual awful self its kind of
worth a listen for these two words be
prepared I hope you guys are ready to
meet Rafiki because he is bound to
become one of your most favorite
characters of all time
Rafiki whose name means friend and
Swahili is not just funny but he is also
incredibly wise and full of some great
advice as a kid you'll either find
yourself totally laughing at Rafiki or
being entirely confused by what he said
as you get older though you such realize
that he's the character most in charge
for almost all the iconic moments and
the
Lion King he definitely helped
somebody's adventure by giving him the
best advice but the way I see it you can
either run from it Oh
that never gets old ask for his the most
iconic moment how can we forget when he
carries someone in the air while playing
the circle of life in the background
definitely the moment we love to relive
with our own pets in the opening scene
of The Lion King we see Rafiki arrive at
a huge celebration with a ton of other
animals he is there to celebrate some of
being born and ultimately being the
future king of Pride Rock in this
ceremony
Rafiki plays the role of a priest he
breaks open a coconut dips his thumb in
the liquid and then swipes it on Simba's
forehead we see this in the trailer for
the new movie however this time he
breaks open a red root as kids we all
remember asking our parents so what
exactly was happening in that scene but
it was surprising that the parents
didn't know either it definitely looks
like some kind of baptism but after some
research I realized that that's not
exactly the case the coconut from the
original movie has a special kind of
liquid in it it's a kind of oil that
they use for anointing ancient tribes
would put the oil on a person just to
emphasize how special they were and this
also became the way of marking the reign
of a new king
sidewalk is the home of Mutasa and his
prize this is where he is able to rule
over the entire animal kingdom
this is also where some of the most
intense parts of the movie take place in
the beginning with Simba ceremony and
even at the end where scar is overthrown
the word pride has brought up many times
throughout the movie and can even be
found in most of the catchy songs now
before your sixth grade English class
you probably didn't know what symbolism
was but there sure is a lot of it in
this movie
lions are symbols for some strong
character traits making it no surprise
that all the lions of this movie live on
Pride Rock scar is a huge character in
the Lion King
not only as he will fauces brother who
turns into the biggest super villain of
the movie he is also a huge symbol for
pride oh yes my curtsy scar tricks then
by keeping him out of the way in time
for him to kill his own brother because
of scars pride greed and jealousy he
will do anything to get to the top of
Pride Rock when Simba thinks that this
is his fault we see the entire pride
land oh great and dead this is to
symbolize that symbol loses all his
pride and hope with scar being the only
person left to take over not all hope
was lost though because thanks to the
lioness Nala Simba was able to get back
his place as king of the pride lands
bringing back harmony and happiness
being a king especially a Lion King
isn't easy but it's all scar has ever
wanted life's not fair it's clear that
once he gets to the top of Pride Rock
nobody is happy about it so why didn't
they do anything about it well to answer
that question you kind of need to
understand how the lion life works
for starters the score had an entire
army of hyenas
but nothing the entire line kingdom
couldn't handle in a typical lion pride
there is a lot more lionesses than male
Cubs Disney actually did a great job and
mimicking how actual lion prides work
with the exception of singing and
dancing of course
when scar is the only male lion left the
rest of the pride is forced to let him
be the king they were kind of forced to
accept this because of some lion pride
bull in this case though we can't help
but feel that sometimes rules
were meant to be broken it's a
comforting thought that after this
entire adventure thanks be work out in
the end he just can't wait to grow up
and be king and follow in his father's
footsteps
which he does literally I'm one of the
last things the kids today probably
won't understand is just how much you're
going to grow up and still love this
movie it's characters catchy songs and
beautiful scenery busily flying King
will always remain in your heart as one
of the most beautiful classic movies
that it is and you will find yourself
using the phrase Hakuna Matata more than
you ever thought you would occasionally
you're feeiing pets and babies just like
all the fans before you you've made it
to the end of this video guys and that
is all I have for the 10 things you
probably won't understand about the new
Lion King movie thank you for watching
guys it's your home somewhere and I'll
catch you next time on the thing
[Music]